au
[Musique]
coeur d'une base militaire le père en
driss aumônier dans la mine craignent n
offre à ces soldats sont à ces quelques
instants de répit
derniers moments de paix avant de
rejoindre l'est pour défendre le dombass
les églises sont les rares endroits où
vous trouverez toujours du soutien
ici est le père andry nous au gris sur
gris
il est de tous ceux qui viennent la nuit
[Musique]
pour les soutenir j'essaie de garder le
sourire pour leur envoyer des ondes
positives et un peu de joie aux vieux
maître toujours à choisir les bons mots
pour leur apporter mon soutien va très
bientôt
en ce dimanche des rameaux
la cérémonie se termine par la
bénédiction de circonstance
entre deux départs au fond lemonnier
collecte de l'aide humanitaire
médicaments vivres fait mon match toutes
sortes de produits de première nécessité
sont ensuite redistribuées
nous venons ici prendre des médicaments
pour nos soldats pour les remettre sur
pied les soigner
et de quoi faire les premiers soins par
la foi sans l'action ne vaut rien donc
là où il ya la foi est ici bas il y à ce
qu'on fait pour aider les grands
quotidiens 9 qui n'est pas digne d'un
show d'hier le père landry est plus un
psychologue un guerrier mais dans
quelques jours il rejoindra une nouvelle
fois
les tranchées du dombass certains
soldats viennent me voir et me demande
où est mon art alors je sors macro et je
leur dis voilà mon arme
s'il ya bien une chose que vladimir
poutine est réussie en ukraine c'est
d'unifier une nation jusque là divisés
russophone russophobe orthodoxes
catholiques juifs et musulmans
s'apprêtent ensemble a livré la plus
importante bataille de l'histoire de ce
jeune pays pour le contrôle du donbass